la fusión espinal se realiza en la
columna para soldar dos o más vértebras
usando dispositivos quirúrgicos y
material de injerto óseo
la columna está formada por una serie de
huesos interconectados llamados
vértebras que se extienden desde la base
del cráneo hasta el coxis
cada vértebra se conecta con la que está
arriba y abajo mediante las
articulaciones facetaria permitiendo que
se mueva una con relación a la otra
entre cada vértebra o sea se encuentra
un disco intervertebral amortiguador
las articulaciones facetaria y los
discos intervertebrales trabajan juntos
para permitir el movimiento de la
espalda y el cuello
protegida dentro de la columna vertebral
se encuentra la médula espinal la cual
conecta el cerebro con el resto del
cuerpo
los nervios espinales provienen de la
médula espinal a intervalos regulares su
médico puede recomendar una fusión
espinal si usted presenta alguna de las
siguientes afecciones una vértebra
fracturada movimiento excesivo entre
vértebras provocando inestabilidad y
dolor
spondylus is una afección artrítica
degenerativa que puede causar la pérdida
de la función y estructura normal de la
columna o espondilolistesis una afección
en la cual una vértebra se desliza hacia
adelante con relación a la vértebra que
está a su lado otras afecciones que
pueden necesitar de cirugía son
osteoartritis de las articulaciones
faceta arias una deformidad espinal como
escoliosis cifosis
o un disco protuberante o herniado que
puede ejercer presión sobre el nervio
espinal saliente
la fusión espinal tiene por objetivo
eliminar el movimiento entre las
vértebras afectadas haciendo que la
columna tenga mayor estabilidad y
disminuye el dolor antes del
procedimiento se colocará una vía
intravenosa es posible que se le coloque
un catéter en la vejiga para drenar la
orina las funciones espinales se
realizan bajo anestesia general lo cual
significa que estará dormido mientras
dure la operación
se le insertará un tubo respiratorio por
la boca hasta la tráquea para ayudarlo a
respirar durante el procedimiento
si su cirujano está usando su propio
hueso para la fusión él o ella hará una
incisión sobre su cadera y retirará un
injerto óseo
si su injerto óseo proviene de otro
donante este se extraerá antes de su
procedimiento
si se va a someter a un procedimiento
abierto de la columna lumbar en la
espalda baja usted se acostara boca
abajo y su cirujano hará una incisión
directamente sobre la columna
si se va a someter a una cirugía de la
columna cervical en el cuello su
cirujano normalmente tendrá acceso a
esta área desde la parte frontal en
algunos casos una fusión espinal se
puede realizar usando una técnica
laparoscópica más reciente y menos
invasiva en lugar de realizar una o dos
incisiones grandes una fusión espinal
laparoscópica necesita de varias
incisiones pequeñas clave a través de
las cuales se inserta en el laparoscopio
y los instrumentos quirúrgicos
especiales
usando un taladro de alta velocidad y
otros instrumentos su cirujano retirará
el disco entre los dos cuerpos
vertebrales a unirse
luego su cirujano insertará el injerto
óseo en el espacio entre estas dos
vértebras
el médico posiblemente colocará una
placa y tornillos sobre el injerto para
mantener las vértebras juntas hasta que
se unan en un solo hueso para terminar
el procedimiento su cirujano se dará la
incisión profunda del tejido y la piel
con puntos muchos cirujanos también
colocarán uno o más drenajes por debajo
de la piel que permanecerá en el lugar
por algunos días después del
procedimiento
usted será trasladado a un área de
recuperación para controlarlo el catéter
de la vejiga posiblemente permanecerá en
el lugar por varios días es posible que
usted no pueda comer por un día o dos
después de la cirugía y recibirá
líquidos alimentos por vía intravenosa
se espera que haya dolor durante los
primeros días posteriores a la cirugía y
se le administrarán medicamentos para
controlarlo